gardens
34.4
london james's park 34.3 cavendish in
suffolk 34.1
and santander in suffolk uh 34 degrees
celsius so the hottest place at midday
today was charwood in essex at
34.8 degrees celsius we'll keep across
those rising temperatures for you of
course throughout the afternoon stay
with us here on sky news in a moment
i'll be joined by health expert head
teacher and by the spokesperson for
network rail to look at the impact of
the heatwave on public services
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello and welcome back on what is set to
be one of the hottest days ever recorded
in the uk a red extreme warning in place
across the country for the first time
ever with much of it likely to be hotter
than the caribbean and even the western
sahara or with temperatures set to break
records let's take a look at some other
notable heat waves in british history
back in 1976 the uk faced what was at
the time the driest year for more than a
century as drought plagued the country
as temperatures soared there were two
six day periods when the temperature
reached 32.2 degrees every day the first
time this has been recorded in the uk
the peak temperature that summer was
felt in cheltenham when
35.9 degrees was recorded on the 3rd of
july
then came 1995 which at the time saw the
hottest august on record since
1659 temperatures peaked at 35.2 degrees
and it's now recognised as one of the
hottest summers in the uk's history
sky's shingi marike joins me now live
from reading
still next to that beautiful looking
pool tempting isn't it shingi how are
people managing there
it's awfully tempting and in the last
hour i've actually been handed these
swimming trunks i won't be wearing them
i'm working but someone felt pretty bad
for me and gave me a pair of those we've
been here all morning and we've been
monitoring the temperatures it's
steadily increased the mercury is rising
are about 37 degrees paul side now which
gives you a sense as to how warm it is
if you have a look at our thermometer
here
and i think it's been interesting
talking to people next to the pool about
their approaches to this weather lots of
people changing the rhythms and routines
of their daily life because of this heat
wave it was a lot fuller early on in the
day before it got to about 11 o'clock
and people started leaving which is in
line with the uk health security
agency's assessment that people need to
stay out of the sunshine and in the
shade when it gets to this peak time of
the day we like and when it really
reaches boiling point it's also been
interesting having conversations with
people here about the broader issues
behind this and more than once we've
heard climate change come up people in
the pool have said that this is proof
that the government needs to act this
needs to be looked at because 40 degree
heat in the uk is obviously up to this
point unheard of and the overall sense
is that people have adapted their
routines to
staying at home because of those weather
warnings put in place by the met office
people who are due to travel to london
decided not to go because they saw those
warnings by the rail networks about the
mass disruption some people are even
working from home or i guess working
poolside in their in their swim gear as
they sort of enjoy the day from here
it's quite clear this is the sort of
weather that is forcing people to change
their daily routines and bringing lots
of the country's infrastructure to a
standstill
shingi let's see those trunks again
i thought you might ask me why not so
i'm not a crab man but with that we've
got some crab action going on here um as
i said you will not be seeing me weather
no we want you live in the pool next
hour thank you uh very much for now uh
let's head to cambridge join skies laura
bundock she's in the beautiful botanic
garden in cambridge and laura the
current record i believe was set where
you
are yeah this is officially the place
that holds the record for the hottest
place ever recorded in the uk when it
hits
38.7 degrees back on the 25th of july
2019.
at 10 o'clock this morning they took the
temperature here and it was
31.5 degrees it's definitely hotter than
that now but i'm afraid we're not going
to know until 10 o'clock tomorrow
morning whether or not the record has
been broken that's purely because the
weather recording box can only get
opened at the same time every day
otherwise the science simply uh doesn't
work but the important thing is here at
the botanic garden is that every
measurement that is taken is fed back to
the met office and that's something you
know this isn't a record that the
botanic garden is proud to hold
this is something that they are angry
about they're upset about and they say
it's very much an indication of climate
change and here there are 40 acres where
they've got plants from all different
bits of the united kingdom including dry
gardens mediterranean guns which need
less watering and they're very much keen
to support the work of those climate
scientists to try and figure out what is
going on and the impact it's having not
just on the floor and fauna but on all
of our lives as well so important
scientific work here but yeah this is
officially uh the place that holds the
record for the hottest place ever and
there aren't actually that many people
here today as you can understand it is
really hard it's that kind of hair dryer
feeling when you step out of air
conditioning so few people in the
gardens today most people keeping in the
shade keeping cool keeping up the fluids
and things but we're waiting to see if
temperatures are really going to get
higher and as i say you know we're only
at midday at the moment and things are
kind of starting to get hotter and
hotter we wouldn't even expect those hot
temperatures and for another couple of
hours anyway but we'll keep you posted
here in cambridge
okay laura thank you very much well
across the uk public services are
bracing to be impacted by the high
temperatures ambulance capacity has
increased trains have been cancelled
some schools have even announced that
they're going to close early well
joining me now to answer your questions
are miriam deakin the interim deputy
chief executive of nhs providers head
teacher of wales high school in
rotherham pepe diazio and the chief
spokesperson for network rail kevin
groves uh good to see you all thanks for
joining us trying to keep cool this
afternoon um perhaps we can come to you
uh first of all miriam just explain to
us what the pressure points are today
thank you
we know that
this extreme heat can be very difficult
for people with underlying health
conditions older people and children and
so the nhs is planning for and is seeing
increased demand for urgent and
emergency care services
to make room for that we are seeing some
disruption in some areas of the country
to planned care to ensure that we don't
have people waiting in incredibly hot
ambulances at the hospital front door
and that we've got space within
hospitals to see them and treat them
the weather conditions are also putting
real pressure on the nhs estate
much of which is in need of much greater
investment and is quite hard to manage
even in normal uh weather conditions so
for example we're hearing of operating
theaters having to be put on pause while
the temperature within them has got
under got under control we know that
medicines have to be managed very
carefully at a particular temperature
and we're also hearing that it servers
are being put under pressure so real
pressure on that kind of key nhs uh
infrastructure of course staff are under
real pressure because this all comes on
the back of an increase in coveted
infections and of course our endeavors
to bear down on those care backlogs
which have built up since the pandemic
so very difficult working conditions for
staff always also and trust leaders are
doing all they can to pull out all the
stops to keep both staff and patients as
cool and as comfortable as possible so
we know that many staff are wearing
slightly different uniforms today some
of them are wearing their scrubs instead
of a fuller uniform trusts have bought
up thousands of bottles of water extra
fans we've heard of hospital kitchens
making ice lollies to help keep staff
and patients cool so we're doing all
that we can to keep people as safe and
as comfortable as possible in these very
challenging conditions uh kevin uh let's
speak to you when it comes to network
rail we're hearing about potential uh
cancellations and delays as well what's
the very latest
well still a bit early for that yet
while it's hot it's not really hot and
the blanket speed restrictions we've put
into place across the country across
england and wales have only just been in
for about half an hour
so
the effects of an impact of of that heat
haven't yet been felt on the railway but
people shouldn't be lulled into a false
sense of security that it's going to
remain that way um for instance this
morning it may have taken two and a half
hours to get from london to leeds if you
made that journey now it's more like
five hours so please our message is if
you don't need to travel today and
tomorrow by rail then please don't and
we've seen a lot of people trying to
escape
to the seaside using train services this
morning and i hate to be a killjoy but
please that is not a journey that is
necessary or essential because there's a
chance we may not be able to get you
home if things deteriorate badly this
evening and this afternoon so please
only travel it's absolutely necessary
make sure you're well hydrated and got
some water with you and remember that
the line out of king's cross up to leeds
in york is going to be closed tomorrow
so that journey to leeds while you can
make it today you won't be able to make
it tomorrow
okay uh thank you for that and pepe uh
what are you doing to make school a bit
more comfortable for everybody
so the first thing we did this morning
was make sure that students arrived out
of normal school uniform the vast
majority of our school are here in
shorts t-shirts and hats to make sure
they can keep their heads cool
throughout the day
we're now awaiting lunch time which will
be the real hot spot for us it's 32
degrees here at the moment and the
temperature's due to go up a degree for
every hour throughout the afternoon we
have had some great news that we have a
couple of ice cream bands that have been
ordered and they will be joining us here
on site and i'm sure they'll be very
popular with the young people and we're
using this opportunity to do some extra
learning on climate change and making
sure that our students are well prepared
for looking after themselves into the
future on days like this that may be
more common as we look forward to the
new uh era that we're heading into oh
very clever yeah a good bit of useful
learning today okay let's have a look at
some of the questions we've had in then
uh miriam perhaps you can answer this
one from sean uh staying well and not
needing the nhs is key today and he asks
is it safe for people working outdoors
for instance on building sites uh
wearing ppe
good question thank you sean um well the
key
key messages i think are that the nhs is
there
for those of us who need urgent
emergency care that's very important to
say
but equally very important i think for
employers to work with their staff to
make the necessary adjustments so that
we can all follow the nhs guidance to
stay out of the heat and stay out of the
sun between 11 and 3 keep well hydrated
as we've heard and seek out the shade so
certainly it was good to see in your
package earlier that a lot of the
general public are adhering to those
messages and i do think it's important
that employers do make some of the
adjustments we've just heard about from
the previous spokesperson for example
and do work with their staff to keep
staff as safe
in this extreme heat as possible
yeah so much of this is is down to
common sense really isn't it um kevin a
question from amanda if tarmac melts and
trains a train tracks buckle how will
the repairs be done
well the answer to that is uh overnight
we have to wait for the rails to cool
down as much as possible and then
basically get welders in to chop out the
bits of rail that have buckled put in a
new piece and weld it back together
again needless to say that isn't a thing
that can be done in just a in just a few
minutes that's a few hours job
but the reason we put the speed
restrictions in place is to lessen the
forces uh in the track when it gets
really hot uh fast trains except a lot
more forces in the in the rail and can
force it to buckle so the idea is that
actually by slowing trains down
we're less likely to see those buckles
which is what we are aiming to do
because needless to say a train
traveling quickly over a buckled rail is
not a good place to be and we don't want
to see that
and kevin this might be a
slightly too technical uh question but
why is it in in countries where they
regularly get temperatures uh in the
late 30s 40s the trains run without any
problems and yet here the minute it hits
the high 30s that the tracks start
buckling are they using different types
of track
no no the the answer simple answer to
that is is any railway in the world is
set up to handle about a 45 degree
temperature range so if i was in saudi
arabia and rail engineer i'd set it up
for say be 10 degrees up to 55
degrees centigrade that's because i'm
not gonna have minus five in the winter
but we do in this country so for this uh
for our railway we set it up for about
to handle temperatures around -10 up to
35 and above or below those temperatures
we need to take mitigation actions like
putting the blanket speed restrictions
of course if we're more likely to see
more severe
summers and less severe winters then we
might change our engineering standards
and move that temperature range up the
scale so say -5 to plus 40
in that range but
those decisions are big
long-term decisions that that will take
many years to go through our engineering
standards so the answer is it's the same
for railways across the entire world
they set up their railways and engineer
their railways for their normal climate
but when there are peaks either at the
bottom end or the top end they have to
take these actions as well the railways
in the south of france and spain have
been just as impacted uh this past week
as they have seen temperatures exceed
their normal operating parameters for
their railway
okay very interesting um pepe one for
you from carol due to the increase in
temperatures in the future will schools
and nursing homes be encouraged to
obtain uh air conditioning you you have
some air conditioning i think in your
school do you think as we build schools
going forward it'll be a requirement
well we were lucky enough last week to
be named in the government's latest
cohort of schools that will have a
rebuild in the next two years and i'm
fairly confident that
many of the new classrooms that we'll
get here will be air conditioned and
built to the standards that are far in
excess of the buildings that are in now
which are
1970s concrete buildings that are cold
in the winter and too hot in the summer
and we are very lucky to have as i say
dozens of classrooms that got air
conditioning on a day like today most of
our students will be spending the lunch
hour in those air-conditioned rooms
making sure that we keep them cool and
keep them safe and we've just changed
our duty rotor to allow for that to
happen
and pepper just saying pepe just staying
with you noah robson has been in touch
as well he says who decides whether a
school should remain open and at what
temperature is there a legal requirement
for them to close if indeed there is
i think that's the obligation of the
head teacher that they're able to make
assessment on the ground in the context
that they are given uh from one part of
the country to another there could be
quite uh significant changes in the
temperature it's something that i'm
looking at every hour here today with
we're looking at a temperature that goes
up towards 40 degrees here tomorrow
we've got to make sure that it's safe
for young people and as a head teacher
that's your first priority so it's the
head teacher on the ground that will
make that decision
and uh miriam how do we prepare for the
future if we're going to get more days
like this if we're going to get extended
periods of really hot weather what does
the nhs need to do to adapt
i think events like this really show
that uh capacity in the nhs hasn't kept
pace uh with changing population need
and how the world's evolved so we really
need to work with government i think to
look at nhs funding and make sure we've
got enough capacity across all of our
services so certainly in the ambulance
sector and the acute hospital sector
which you've talked about but also
across community and mental health
services and today really does point to
a pressing need to look at the nhs
estate and really to release as much
capital as possible to modernize some of
the buildings that we're we're dealing
with and trying to provide care within a
lot of those buildings are quite
difficult to manage in normal uk
temperatures and days like today just
really show the acute need to invest in
them more and bring them up to modern
day standards
okay miriam deakin uh from nhs providers
kevin groves from network rail and pepe
diazio head teacher of wales high school
in rotherham matt great to get your
thoughts and comments and answering some
of those questions much appreciated stay
cool and thank you very much
you're with sky news today coming up
after the break the extreme heat has
brought raging fires to southern and
western europe but we're going to have
the very latest from southern france
[Music]
and it was 1989 in australia and some
guy was trying to take me out for a meal
and he was carrying on for a few months
to get me out anyway in the end i said
okay let's go out for a meal and um no
funny business and when we were there we
got to the restaurant and i went to use
the bathroom and i forgot my bag and
when i came back his hand was hovering
and he moved it really quickly and i
thought he's done something to my drink
so i picked up my bag i went into the
bathroom and i thought i'm going to do
like a james bond style and swap the
drinks when i go back but i didn't i
climbed over a little window around for
my life and i never saw that guy again
so
even back in 1989 i knew that this was
happening now thank goodness for all the
brave victims who step forward and thank
goodness for social media because i've
been campaigning for nearly two decades
now banging on the doors of the
authorities to say to them look this is
a real problem but because of the drugs
and because people have no memory what's
happened to them it does make the
police's job really difficult and with
students it's very prevalent they could
use rehypnol ghb gbl they could use
prescription drugs like the tamazipan
family
yeah and they'll leave you with no
memory of what's happened to you um
you'll become compliant you'll leave
with the assailant and then like i say
you'll be left with no memory of what's
happened to you
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
navigate your way to the right outcome
invest in your future sky news financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
[Music]
invest in your future sky news financial
report sponsored by interactive investor
now in southern and western europe
authorities have been battling to
control huge wildfires in countries
including spain greece and france
temperatures are extremely high across
the continent and spain is expected to
experience 42 degrees celsius today and
as temperatures drop in the uk on
wednesday they will still stay high in
southern europe well this footage was
filmed this morning in northern spain it
shows moments of panic on a train
traveling from the capital madrid to the
city of farrell the train stopped
because of wildfires
and passengers were able to see the
flames on both sides
from the train windows pretty terrifying
that isn't it it was able to continue on
its journey after a few minutes everyone
was safe scott shawn robbins has the
latest now from bordeaux in the west of
france
i'm here in the command center in
bordeaux where they're working together
to try and tackle these massive fires
that have broken out in south west
france so you can see that we've got
here
representatives of the army there are
police there as well fire brigade too
and what they're doing
just had a dream area as well as getting
locals out and we can have a look at a
map here to show you the where the fires
are that they're tackling so we've got
one here which is by the coast five
campsites evacuated here more than four
thousand hectares of land already burnt
and then here is the other massive one
that they've been trying to bring under
control more than 9 000 hectares of land
burnt there in total 16 000 people have
been evacuated from their homes here
more than 1700 firefighters now on the
scenes trying to bring both of those
blazes under control the problem they
had is today was really the deadline
this was where they were trying to get
them under control by because the heat
is so strong here it's going to be at
least 40 degrees in this area somewhere
the forecasters are calling this an
apocalypse of heat because so many areas
of france are affected by lunch time
they're expecting every single city in
this country to be at least 30 degrees
and of course it's not just the fires
that are putting lives at risk it's also
the heat
across europe so in france
and spain and portugal we've been seeing
all of these fires over the last week we
know in spain and portugal more than a
thousand people have died of heat and
because these fires haven't been able to
be brought under control at the weekend
now they're really really battling it
the issue they had over the weekend was
the wind was whipping around 360 degrees
it's happening in pine forest which is
adding fuel to those fires and really
really now everything is being put in to
try and stop this before temperatures
hopefully drop again tomorrow
just before the weather let me tell you
about the singer jennifer lopez she's
married the hollywood actor ben affleck
in las vegas three months after
confirming their engagement and 18 years
after cancelling their first wedding the
couple were previously engaged back in
2002 but called off the wedding both
went on to have families with different
partners before rekindling their
relationship last year and getting
married
okay let's get the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
as we've been reporting it's going to be
hot over the next couple of days with a
risk of dangerous record-breaking
temperatures but it will turn cooler by
wednesday the met office has a red
warning of extreme heat in force for
much of central england while amber
warnings cover the rest of central and
southern britain it's going to be hot
for most this afternoon very hot for
england and wales but the far north will
be cooler most places will be dry plenty
of sunshine into the evening but the far
north will be dull and damp for a time
the hebrews will turn gray later
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
[Music]
so
[Music]
you